Trascrizione: Clarissa Candellero
Revisore: Gaia Daineli
Innanzitutto, buonasera.
Oggi viviamo in un momento
di alta complessità,
in cui piccole variabili possono
determinare grandi cambiamenti.
In cui è impossibile capire
cosa verrà dopo, cosa succederà.
Siamo immersi in una grandissima
quantità di dati.
Però, accedere alle informazioni,
accedere alle persone è facile.
Accedere alle informazioni sulle persone.
Su di noi si aprono tantissime finestre,
finestre che passano
da Twitter, da Facebook,
dalle fotografie che postiamo,
dal nostro profilo e dai video.
E le persone iniziano a farsi un'idea
di noi che viene prima di noi stessi.
Quest'idea porta gli altri a coinvolgerci
in alcuni progetti o a non coinvolgerci,
a invitarci ad alcuni eventi e altro.
E allora, noi professionisti,
come possiamo rispondere a tutto questo?
La chiave è l'autenticità,
l'essere veri,
basare la nostra reputazione
su quello che veramente facciamo,
sul valore che creiamo,
sulle nostre reali capacità.
La reputazione e l'identità
sono diventati ormai degli asset chiave,
di cui non possiamo fare a meno.
La reputazione, però, di cui parlo,
è un tipo che in 'Cocoon Projects',
l'organizzazione di cui faccio parte,
definiamo reputazione operativa.
Cioè, quella reputazione basata
proprio sul valore concreto
che andiamo a realizzare,
sulle nostre reali capacità,
sul contributo che diamo
alla nostra comunità.
Se riusciamo a fare questo
diverremo centro di una rete.
Saremo riconosciuti per questo,
diverremo autorevoli,
diverremo un punto di riferimento.
Se riusciamo a costruire
la nostra reputazione operativa,
riusciremo anche
ad attrarre ciò che ci serve.
Oggi dovremmo accedere
(per evolvere e crescere)
a tantissimo materiale,
perché le cose vanno velocissime.
Dovremmo leggere tantissimi
articoli, video ed eventi.
Non si può fare tutto,
e allora bisogna attrarre
quello di cui abbiamo bisogno
e anche attrarre quello
di cui non sappiamo che abbiamo bisogno.
L'attrazione non è qualcosa che capita,
è sempre il frutto di qualcosa
che, consapevolmente
o inconsapevolmente, abbiamo determinato.
E allora, se il nostro collega,
il nostro amico,
ci manda quell'articolo
che proprio riguardava quello
che stiamo studiando,
se veniamo invitati proprio
a quell'evento, non è un caso.
Le persone, in questo contesto,
diventano fondamentali.
Proprio le persone.
Perché noi da loro impariamo.
Queste persone ci danno feedback,
condividiamo le esperienze, gli errori,
ci fanno da specchio,
ci aprono ad altre persone,
diventano dei nodi.
Proprio su tutto questo,
abbiamo sviluppato uno strumento
che si chiama 'core square',
cioè cuore al quadrato.
Si chiama così perché
(vedete lì i quadranti)
le iniziali dei quadranti sono 'CO'
di 'competencies' di competenze.
'RE' di relazioni,
'CO', di nuovo, di contribution
e 'RE' di 'resonance', risonanza.
È uno strumento iterativo che ci aiuta
a sviluppare la reputazione operativa.
A crescere, ci aiuta a evolvere,
come professionisti,
a livello della nostra professione.
Ed è uno strumento iterativo,
quindi si parte da competenze
poi lavoriamo sulle nostre relazioni,
sul contributo che diamo
alla nostra comunità di riferimento,
facciamo, lavoriamo sulla risonanza
e ritorniamo sulle nostre competenze,
ancora una volta.
Però, ritorniamo sulle nostre competenze
con la visibilità e consapevolezza
che non avevamo prima.
Cresciamo a ogni giro.
Come vedete, c'è l'asse che va
da competenze a contributo,
che è quello del "know-how",
del contributo che do agli altri,
di cui parlavamo anche prima.
E poi, c'è l'asse delle relazioni
e della risonanza
che è quello sulle persone.
Ogni quadrante è collegato
ad una griglia,
in cui vado a rispondere
a delle domande molto concrete.
Cioè 'specific goal',
mi do degli obiettivi specifici
da raggiungere
in ognuno dei quadranti.
Vado a definire
delle azioni chiave,
'key activities', dei 'KPI', quindi
'key performance indicator',
e dei 'key learning'.
In ogni quadrante imparo delle cose
che poi utilizzerò anche
sugli altri quadranti.
Io ho supportato tantissime persone,
utilizzando questo strumento.
Persone molto diverse,
perché avevano storie diverse.
Perché avevano un profilo differente,
caratteri differenti,
un lavoro diverso.
Però, tutti erano accomunati,
alla fine delle giornate
che facevamo,
che erano anche molto faticose,
e poi anche lungo tutto il percorso
di evoluzione, da una luce.
Una luce, una carica, un'energia
che derivava dall'essere andati
verso un miglioramento,
essere cambiati.
Aver superato dei limiti
che si pensava di avere.
Essere usciti fuori
dalla propria zona di comfort.
Aver visto il prossimo passo
che volevano fare.
Quando lavoriamo sul 'core square',
lavoriamo anche utilizzando
quest'altro strumento,
che si chiama
'personal work system canvas',
che va a lavorare sull'identità,
e ci porta a focalizzarci,
a rispondere ad alcune domande.
Domande come:
i miei punti di forza,
oppure quali sono i benefici
che io porto ai miei 'stakeholder',
oppure quali sono i 'creation
space' in cui io devo agire.
I 'creation space', qui,
nella chiave di John Hagee.
Quindi quei momenti e quei luoghi
in cui scorrono flussi di conoscenza.
Dove trovo le persone
e le risorse per migliorare.
Perché l'identità?
L'identità, perché quando so chi sono,
so anche dove voglio andare.
È qualcosa con cui non nasciamo,
è qualcosa che evolviamo vivendo.
E si basa ed è influenzata
dalle nostre scelte,
da quello che decidiamo di fare,
dalle nostre azioni,
dalle nostre aspirazioni,
dai nostri obiettivi.
Ed è influenzata fortemente
dalle nostre esperienze.
Soprattutto quelle esperienze
che io definisco
esperienze trasformative.
Sono quelle esperienze
che definiscono un prima e un dopo.
Ognuno di voi, se parliamo di esperienze
trasformative, penserà a cosa diverse.
Penserà al corso di yoga
che mi ha insegnato a respirare.
Penserà al corso di apnea che mi ha
insegnato a svuotare la mente, non lo so.
Io, quando penso a esperienze
trasformative, penso ai viaggi.
Questa è Cuba.
Io sono tornata da Cuba cambiata.
A parte, insomma, potrei
raccontarvi tanti aneddoti,
però, quello che più di tutto ho imparato,
è stato non dare nulla per scontato.
La normalità o quella che io penso
che ci sia e la mia normalità,
non è la normalità di tutti.
Se io vado in giro e penso di collegarmi
con il mio smartphone a Internet
e accedere a qualunque sito io voglia,
bene, non è così in tutto il mondo.
Però, quando lo tocchi con mano,
ti rimane impresso e dici: cavolo!
Non devo dare nulla per scontato.
Altra esperienza
trasformativa: mio figlio.
Cinque mesi fa sono diventata mamma.
È stata un'esperienza
che mi ha cambiato tanto.
Leo mi sta insegnando
ogni giorno cose diverse.
Forse, la cosa che mi ha
insegnato di più, è la gratitudine.
Quello che io imparo
nella mia vita personale
lo porto nel mio lavoro,
lo porto nei miei clienti.
E allora perché non pensare
che quello che imparo sul lavoro
lo porto, lo posso portare
anche nella mia vita personale.
Sono due sfere
che si nutrono l'un l'altro,
non sono due sfere separate.
Il lavoro posso iniziare
a vederlo come uno spazio
in cui sperimentare.
Uno spazio veramente per crescere.
Lì ho delle risorse,
ho delle sfide, ho delle persone,
e allora perché non iniziare
a vederlo in questo modo?
Proprio sul lavoro
io ho imparato una cosa
che poi mi ha cambiato tantissimo.
Questo è il training
di LEGO Serious Play,
una metodologia che usiamo tantissimo e...
dove ho preso la certificazione
e sono diventata un facilitatore
certificato in questa metodologia.
Quello che ho imparato è stato che
il sapere della parte emozionale
è importante tanto
quanto quello razionale.
Che quello che sento sui temi è
importante tanto quanto quello che penso.
Questo, mi ha portato, a catena,
a cambiare tantissime cose,
e questo training
fa parte del mio lavoro.
Non sembra, perché ci sono i LEGO,
i mattoncini, ma è così, fidatevi!
È una metodologia,
tra l'altro, potentissima.
Sto parlando di un cambio di prospettiva,
di vedere le cose in un modo diverso.
Di vedere il mio lavoro
in un modo diverso.
Se inizierò a farlo, magari,
inizierò a fare alcune cose
in un'altra chiave e
non farò più alcune azioni,
o ne farò di nuove.
Oppure farò le stesse identiche cose,
ma in un modo diverso.
Quando lo riconosciamo negli altri
questo modo di vivere il proprio lavoro,
lo vediamo subito.
E... brillano.
Se davvero ci crediamo
possiamo iniziare ad avere un impatto
sul nostro ecosistema.
Nutrirlo, farlo evolvere.
Se iniziamo a farlo, come un virus,
infetteremo le persone intorno a noi.
E allora, il tutto, il cambiamento
che riusciremo a determinare,
sarà più delle singole parti.
Gibran dice: "Il lavoro
è l'amore reso visibile".
È una frase, secondo me, meravigliosa.
Io ci credo davvero a questa cosa.
Il punto è iniziare a vivere
il nostro lavoro in questa chiave.
E allora davvero saremo
portatori di un cambiamento
nel nostro ecosistema,
in noi e anche fuori di noi.
Grazie.